on ne bouge pas elle a bougé vais bouger
là on recommence aura lieu attention je
vais vous faire une interview première
fois
elle peut pas s'empêcher à vous êtes
tough raconte bien premier souvenir
bonjour j'ai rencontré jean françois
lamour en guadeloupe
il est venu en plus envoyé après la télé
vous avez allaité lille est plus
vraiment moi aussi j'ai rencontré
l'amour était le jour il m'a signé le
premier autographe
ouais bah c'est grand souvenir c'est
vrai a décidé de votre premier péché dit
la vérité ici on dit la vérité c'est pas
comme d'habitude à la télé ici on dit la
vérité
j'ai écouté les bonbons de mon frère et
j'avais juré que c'était pas moi
moi je m'attendais à un prix beaucoup
plus hard à ses premiers essais le
premier bon deuxième à la première idole
jean françois lamour ont fait dire oui
c'était pas de mots non c'était quand
lewis à carl lewis les premiers amours
mauvais souvenirs à vent mauvais
souvenir non c'est aller trimer as tu es
un escrimeur encore dans les films non
non tu devrais dire il serait mal c'est
vrai ce que tu fous merde moi bon
premier les fleurs il tirait mal non
plus le même ouais premier robe premier
amour premiers flirts premier homme
c'est le même escrimeurs zéro pointé
c'est ça oui ça plaît à tous
c'est votre première cuite
jonathan toujours jean heureusement peur
du lendemain donc je ramène plutôt que
20 morts le 1er juin
ou encore vous êtes tout à découvrir
attendait mais c'est le formidable
décalage titan twittant premier dopage
et j'envisage pas ah bon vous devez pas
vous non pour le moment je fais comment
moi c'est sûrement va comment collection
tour du monde sans vous dopez mons
entraînant et en croyant en étant
entouré par une bonne part de bonnes
personnes
c'est beau surtout que je suis passionné
donc aux usa s'applaudissent à janvier
mais mon sens bien vendu